he is the quarterback of the Dallas
Cowboys joining us from New York City
where he's hanging out with our good
friend Eric Stonestreet from Modern
Family as part of the ready raise rise
campaign to raise awareness about cancer
research he is dak Prescott how are you
dad I'm doing well I adore it
I am doing fine what were you doing on
this very date last year when you were
presumed to be the third string
quarterback going into training camp for
the Dallas Cowboys
I can definitely tell you I wasn't doing
what I'm doing today maybe I don't have
no idea what I was doing back then just
trying to work out and get on the field
well when did you first realize then
that you had a shot at at raising your
your awareness if you will amongst the
coaching staff up the drought the be the
depth chart there in Dallas
Jack uh I mean I don't know just earlier
when I was just going in I was third
string behind Tony and kelan and it was
just about giving myself a chance to
move in the second string to to just
show the coaches what I had to offer and
then unfortunately training camp kelan
went down then when kelan goes down Tony
actually took the next day off as a
break just you know just from age and
and health-wise and I stepped in and
practice with the ones and I think from
that moment going forward I knew that I
had the ability and I had the confidence
in myself that that I could play if they
needed me to so it was that day after
kelan went down and it was a schedule
rest day for Tony you get in there and
you thought amongst just in between your
temples I can do this
yeah I mean I go on the huddle and you
look around and you see all those pro
ball players and Hall of Fame Jason
Witten and it just kind of raises your
play raise your elevation of play and
focus and I knew from that moment what
it took to stand that hold on and I just
I felt as I said but to myself that I
can play honestly did and when Tony did
then go down in that preseason game
against Seattle did you at any point
walk into Jason Garrett's office and say
I got this oh no I did I mean what Tony
goes down I'm thinking third and eight
and and as that's all I'm thinking I
give credit to the coaches and everyone
for an allowing me to think so calm and
then that just kind of the season road
is we didn't think about anything we
thought about what was ahead of us and
what was I was now for us to do well how
are you able to keep your head and all
that stack seriously oh you have just I
mean stand focus on I think it shows it
goes back to my mom and just everything
that she told me of just being focused
and being grounded and then obviously
watching her her fight through cancer
and that's why I'm part of this this
campaign of the ready raise rise
campaign and just everything that my mom
meant to me and everything that she
taught me losing her as a sophomore in
college only 20 years old there was so
much that she told me then I had losing
her and that fight was so important to
me now it's my turn to raise awareness
and to help many Americans going through
what I went through so you're saying
that that lent you perspective for
things like say going from third on the
depth chart to top and Tony Romo maybe
coming back and taking the job and you
being able to just matriculate the ball
down the field weekend weekend that
essentially I mean yeah it does because
that's something that that I couldn't
really control what I could control was
me playing well I mean whatever verse
and what it has that connection to my
mom is all I could control support my
mom and helping her and I couldn't
control whether Tony came back and
started I couldn't control whether my
mom passed away or not what I can
control is helping her out having a good
spirit that's the same way I think about
the game of football is all I can
control is me getting better and helping
my teammates out and then staying
focused and true to myself so and and
will definitely return to the subject of
your mom especially because it's part of
the campaign that you're doing why do
you think so many teams missed on you
that Dec I'm not really sure I think
that arm at the quarterback position
it's hard to judge what's in someone's
heart and in between those temples as
you say and I think that's a lot of the
game if you watch paid man you watch Tom
Brady and all these guys that have had
tons of success in this league
they've won with their mind they've won
with their knowledge of the game and I
think that's something that that's hard
to judge and they've won by being good
leaders and I think that's something
that is truly hard to judge in the
little time that they're gay
in the draft process and you can ask
college coaches and college teammates
and the equipment guys how they act but
for the most part I mean every guy's
going to be biased so I think that
hesitant coaches that even though as
highs Mississippi State had me that they
were just biased rather than then it was
true that that's the way I am I want to
know everything I can about the game I
want to put my teammates first and push
them to be better dak Prescott joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show so what
advice would you give to Shawn Watson -
Shawn Kaiser and top drafted rookies who
are going into this season and training
camp not atop their depth chart what
advice would you give them dak as I just
said control the things that you can
control on the one thing they can do is
they can control how fast they learn
that playbook and regardless of whether
they it's watching film or writing it
down that study that tells us make sure
they're learning as much as they can as
quick as they can and giving themselves
a chance an opportunity to be ready to
play if their numbers called and when
there's numbers number is called and
then being true Bichir themselves if
their locker room got the wrong guy be
that if you're not don't necessarily try
to be that just be yourself and and I
get to know your teammates and I get to
earn their respect I think the best way
you can do that is by actions of man
that's the way I felt like I did have
earned in the respect of a guy like
Jason Witten was not going to talking to
Jason Witten every day but was studying
my playbook giving myself a chance to
win and help Jason Witten out and I'll
just staying focused and I think those
young guys can do well in this league I
know they have all the talent but if
they they stay true themselves and study
this playbook they have a chance well
what was Tony Romo's role in you being
able to ascend and also control what you
can control
jack oh yeah me Tony did an amazing job
of helping me out and I think that's
what we're trying to realize is that he
couldn't necessarily control whether he
was going to play or not but what he
could control was our relationship and
me and Tony Alfred did a great job and I
commend Tony and thank you so much for
that of being another coach formula
helping me out of on the game in the
middle of a game at practice on the
field off the field giving me advice and
as a guy
as he went through exactly what I went
through have taken over the position
from an older veteran I know what it's
like to be a quarterback of the Dallas
Cowboys I'm just helping me out so they
never get uncomfortable dunk it truly
never did just in the fact that's why I
commend him is I mean I don't know how
he felt personally I mean I was
obviously I know as much of a competitor
he is then he wanted to play that as
much success as he had literally he
probably felt that he should play but it
never did as I said he always was so
helpful to me I felt it was genuine and
I commend them for that couple more
minutes for dak Prescott a Dallas
Cowboys here alright let's get to your
mom who was she was your mom dad my hero
everything to me the one that would go
out there in the summer of when I was in
college in town my 40s and tamo my
conditioning that I stayed on me about
my grades and education with a selfless
hard-working woman I think it shows
through me and not only me but my
brothers and and other people she
affected with in her life and and her
passing how did that obviously I one
would know or assume how the passing of
a mom would affect a devoted son but how
did it affect you as you were trying to
make a career for yourself and get an
education for yourself right in the
middle of college losing your mom jack
yeah losing my sophomore year just makes
you grow up faster and it makes you
become a man a lot quicker and my mom
told me what she was sick to allow her
to be my story and then hearing that at
20 years old 19 or whatever was that she
told me she'd say that's the last thing
I'm I don't need a story if it means you
haven't cancer but losing her and then
that's immediately what I did I said I'm
going to make my mom my story and I'm
going to get my get my degree I'm gonna
get my Master's put everything I have
into the game of football because that's
what my mom would want me to do and now
it's given me this amazing platform to
honor my mom not only on the football
field but off in this campaign already
raised rising and helping other family
members out that as I said can relate to
what I'm going or what I went through I
know what they're going through is it
true you text your mom on occasion day
yeah I mean I go to the notes on the
iPhone and just simply just write
sometimes
as I said everything when I vented to
the one I would show my weaknesses to on
the side times that allows me to do that
of just getting it out of me of just
going to my notes and then just simply
just writing away and it definitely
helps how many times did you put
something in your notes on your phone
last year during the season yeah I mean
a few times a couple of times during the
season
no preseason I know the first game I
ever played
training camp just situations where me
and my mom talked about as a kid growing
up of when to play an NFL if one to play
for the Dallas Cowboys up and then
reaching those moments those in those
moments when you're on the foot where
I'm on the the steps of doing that or
I'm at the door about to open it up
those are times that that allows me to
just humble myself and allow me to
realize where I came from is just to go
to those notes and I talked to my mom
ready raise rise calm the goal is to
raise a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars for research by the end of next
month that's how people can get involved
to trying and try and eradicate cancer
as best we can dad oh yeah July 31st
that's the deadline and the goal that we
want to we want to reach and as simple
as you said go to ready raise raise calm
on these actions that you can take on
there with each action you receive a
point and actions are sending the e card
to a family member may be the one that's
going through cancer to brighten their
day educating yourself on
immuno oncology research or just the way
that we can help fight against cancer
and my personal favorite is raising the
flag for cancer as the support is there
just your your knowledge supporting of
that person as I did for my mom as I
said each eye each action you get a
point and then bristol-myers Squibb is a
promise to donate one hundred fifty
thousand dollars we when we reach our
goal a bunch a lot thirty first and I
saw you were on Good Morning America and
you've been campaigning with Eric
Stonestreet you do know as I'm sure he
bent your ear about this he's a die-hard
Chiefs fan
Jack yeah trust me we've talked about
November the fifth when just on AT&T
Stadium and so we've covered that okay
how did you cover that
in a way doc I mean is he coming yeah
I'm gonna be there you need he said he's
going to try to be that he's working on
his schedule I said he doesn't know how
the filming and that time is as far as
the way that is but he's going to try to
be there as you said it's now her chief
and it is and then I promised him that
he would see a good game from the
Cowboys and I didn't I didn't know if at
all the games of chief said he wanted to
come to that but we joked back and forth
and had a good time we did on Good
Morning America and half throughout this
morning and so I guess season two just
to wrap it up dak I mean how how how to
improve on this I mean what an
incredible year you had with Ezekiel
Elliott back there the two of you guys
what you did for Dallas just did double
handedly right there how do you follow
this up dak Prescott uh yeah I mean I
think it just goes in to the stand true
to myself knowing everything that it
took for me to get here and that nothing
needs to change and the fact that I
think just honestly simple those
messages that I send my mom or just
keeping myself grounded knowing the hard
work is going to take the only thing
that matters is what I can control
there's helping my teammates getting
better at the quarterback position on
and off the field
and give a central in just given the
Dallas Cowboys a chance to win every
game and and as much as I love you rich
not listening to the media and the
critics and what people have to say of
just focusing on my game on the Dallas
Cowboys and as I said helping easy can
des and getting the defense right and I
think we give ourselves a good chance
and I know I'm going to get better off
for thinking that well last place well
since you said you love me dad can you
give me em can you send a message from
me to Ezekiel Elliott can you do that I
can do that okay say this is from Rich
Eisen say enjoy the Michigan Wolverines
you just drafted okay enjoy and don't
let him forget that the next first-round
selection after him for the Dallas
Cowboys was a Michigan Wolverine okay
and that to over is in this dress that
is correct
you got Jordan Lewis and you got taco
Charlton and they are going to ball out
on the defensive side just by the way
this is all stuff you're supposed to
tell zekiel
and and say that we will see you this is
we in November okay that works that
works I got you thank you jack
I appreciate that [ __ ] it you got any
revenue you got its dak Prescott of the
Dallas Cowboys here on the richer so
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy